Black Magic - this is the name of Loyiso Mkize's fifth solo exhibition, which he is currently
preparing for.
But his art has nothing to do with evil spirits.
For Loyiso Mkize, it's about the black experience transforming into something beautiful and
powerful.
I believe that we as a people, particularly
in Africa, are going through a really exciting
transition right now in history.
We come from a very horrific history and there is a sense of self now that is very different
and very urgent.
Cause I believe our story is yet to be told
in its totality.
Social media played a defining role in Mkize’s career: After his work was discovered online
in 2014, he was commissioned to do nine pieces for Momentum, an action film starring Morgan
Freeman.
Soon Mkize’s work caught the interest of
galleries and art dealers.
His powerful portraits reveal the dignity
of his subjects, while addressing major social
issues.
Tonight Mkize will celebrate the opening of Black Magic in a Cape Town gallery.
It is relevant because what I see what kind of topics he explores is like you know the
black identity is a lot present in his work
and how he is trying to promote you know the
fact that you should be proud of who you are and he is really proud of his own background
and he is trying to bring that across in his
work.
Mkize explores themes of power, African heritage, and modernity, not only as a painter, but
also as a comic book artist.
He is the creator of Kwezi - a superhero who lives in a squatter camp.
Kwezi has to learn to embrace his African
identity first, before he can use his powers
to fight evil and corruption.
Kwezi is popular with young South African’s - such as Kirsten Muller, who we meet in a
popular bar.
A Kwezi fan, she immediately recognises Mkize and joins us at our table.
I really just like the fact that South Africa
now has like an actually comic book that we
can call our own you know and our characters we can relate to them.
Mkize sees many hidden super-human qualities
in the younger generation of South Africans.
With his African heroes, Mkize wants to change young people’s frame of reference and create
positive imagery that helps them to see their history and identity in an empowering light.
What we know about super heroes, we know that they embody our greatest ambition as human
beings.
And that I think says a lot about the potential number one of the people that we take for
granted in South Africa.
The people that come from the township that come from the villages you know and that’s
what super hero comic books are about.